انسحب الاحتلال من مخيم نور شمس بعد عمليه
عسكريه استمرت ع ساعات في هذه المنطقه فجر
الاحتلال احد المنازل في هذه الاثناء
وانسحب بعد ذلك على الفور نرصد هذه
الصوره الحصريه في هذه الاثناء لحاله
الدمار التي خلفها الاحتلال على وقع
العمليه العسكريه في هذا المنزل الاحتلال
قام بتفخيخ هذا المنزل ومن ثم بعد ذلك قام
بنس ف وانسحب بعد ذلك على الفور حاله من
الدمار التي شهدتها المنطقه منذ ساعات
الليل وتحديدا في هذه اللحظات بعد تفجير
هذا المنزل بشكل كامل ما ادى لاشتعال
واشتعال النيران في كافه ارجاء هذا المنزل
نرصد في هذه الصوره ايضا هنا في الجهه
الاخرى للمنطقه حيث الدمار الذي تشهده في
هذه اللحظات هذه المنطقه وايضا حاله النار
التي يعني بدات بالاشتعال فعليا في
المنطقه من الجهه الاخرى
ل المنزل يعني في هذه اللحظات على ما يبدو
ان المنزل اشتعل بالكامل ايضا في هذه
الصوره
اشتعال النيران في داخل هذا
المنزل في
هذه اللحظات كما
تشاهدون اشتعال للنيران بشكل كامل ليس فقط
في المنزل الذي تم استهدافه وانما في عدد
من المنازل المحيطه لهذا المنزل اذا
الاحتلال انسحب من المخيم بعد ع ساعات على
بدء هذه العمليه لا يوجد اصابات ولكن
الاحتلال قام بتفخيخ ونصف المنزل بالكامل
من مخيم نور شمس ليث جعار
الجزيره